[Musica]
nient'altro se non ce lo statico un volo
obliquo e concentrico di ganz sigillato
nel buio delle anfore la formula perduta
il vasaio disperso tra odori di menta e
di scrittura dentro un rumore d'acqua
millenaria gli occhi spaventati di mia
madre in un interno ci stanno per
crollare
nient'altro sull'altura delle argille
insomma tra i calanchi alta di notte
sulla pianura
la città di cui parlo in questi miei
versi è la mia città
caltagirone questa città sugli e ray che
ha una storia d'argilla e di calanchi e
di ceramica di colori di bellezza ma
anche di profondità di storia e
caltagirone prova nella sua circoscritta
spazialità sua brevità nonis paggio è la
città dove sono nata
ma è anche la città che matrice della
mia scrittura sia della mia scrittura
poetica che della mia scrittura
narrativa benché alla narrazione sono
arrivata dopo infatti ho cominciato con
la poesia e ricordo esattamente quando
però è il giorno in cui ho scritto la
prima poesia perché quella è stata
un'esperienza fondante e fondamentale
della mia scrittura perché quel giorno
ho trovate ho scoperto io e quello
scritto il regista dello scrivere è
stato dettato proprio da queste due
dimensioni che ho percepito e ripeto
sono costitutive della mia scritto
riordino della scrittura
la prima è questa quando scrissi quella
prima poesia avvertito un profondo senso
di come se all'improvviso avessi
scoperto la verità un'apertura
conoscitiva diciamo no ecco una profonda
esperienza di verità in quel momento è
anche una profonda esperienza di verità
che
aveva diciamo ecco che doveva allora un
linguaggio che non le parole a dirla e
quindi queste esperienze di assoluta
libertà delle parole di fronte a cui mi
trovavo e che potevo usare come volevo
allora ero un piccola era adolescente le
parole usate in modo diciamo ecco
abbastanza banale però poi crescendo la
scrittura la parola divenne ricerca
diventa necessità divenne eco esperienza
profonda del linguaggio luce del
linguaggio e quindi arrivare alla parola
della poesia che ha continuato diciamo a
ad accompagnarmi mi accompagna tuttora
mancando la poesia
poi è venuta la narrazione ed è venuta
dopo è venuta dopo perché ed è venuta
quando ecco dal dal linguaggio dell'io
che il linguaggio della poesia in fondo
da quelli sa cos'è sentire se stesse e
il mondo attraverso il filtro di lio e
quindi attraverso il linguaggio del io
ecco quando un certo punto ho sentito il
bisogno del linguaggio del mondo senti
il mondo l'esperienza del mondo dovevo
quel linguaggio volevo raccontare il
mondo e tralascia il linguaggio del
mondo
e a questo punto ecco devo dire che
questo l'ho avvertito allorquando sono
passata diciamo dalla da me dalla mia
identità singolare figlia di mia madre
di mio padre e della mia città
un'identità plurale figlia cioè della
storia cioè quando ho scoperto in me e
attorno a me che io ero storici da non
era solo un individuo
ero tanti individui e non noi non ero
più solo ovvio
ecco questo l'ho scoperto anche
attraverso e scoprendo la mia dimensione
storica di essere in mezzo agli altri
ho scoperto diciamo che queste siano
accompagnato da una profonda azione
politica per me oggi si parla mario
della politica si marra parla male della
utopia ma non è così la politica aiuto
via e non venir in se stessi e
continuare o nell'altro è cosa per
sapere riceve per esempio certo lotti
per qualcosa cioè un progetto di
in cui credi in cui noi per me è il
progetto di mandera un progetto che
doveva essere senza ingiustizie sociali
e senza discriminazione di genere
ecco questo progetto di mondo non era
solo mio e una delle persone che magari
dall'altra parte del pianeta lottavano
per le stesse cose
dall'altra parte dell'italia quindi non
finivo in me stessa ma c'era questa
continuità nello spazio con gli altri
insieme agli altri ma c'era anche
insieme a chi lo stava per le stesse
cose come me anche se a distanza anche
se in australia un america o a niscemi
qualsiasi vostra ero loro sorella loro
fratello la stessa cosa
ecco questo per quanto riguarda il ecco
il senso della riconosciamo degli altri
di essere insieme agli altri ma non è
una questione solo di spaccio di
spazialità io non ero solo compagna
delle mie sorelle dei miei fratelli del
presente no dello spazio del tempo
presente ma anche di quelli che nel
passato
dico a partire proprio dal profondo dei
tempi mi senti io sentivo di
rappresentare non solo me stessa ma
anche loro e non solo io ma tutti quelli
che lottiamo per un mondo diverso
rappresentavo tutti quelli che avevano
creduto e lottato e combattuto per avere
una dimensione storica diciamo diversa
di genere diverso
ecco quindi mi sentivo ecco legata non
solo nello spagna che al presente ma va
al passato anche il passato alle donne
agli uomini che avevano lottato avevano
resistito all'esistente è un mondo
ingiusto
devo dire che questo è stato l'inizio
ecco questo è stato l'inizio della mia
storia le storie quindi visto io scrivo
prevalente romanzi storici o quantomeno
di ambientazione storica
ecco questa perché scrivo questa queste
roma queste storie
le scrivo perché è co trovo delle e
trovo nella verticalità del tempo nel
per me una mia identità in fondo alla
particolarità del tempo cos'è la
particolarità del tempo e cos'è il tempo
ecco e tutto questo lo trovo nella mia
città a caltagirone 1 cammina per
esempio in uno spazio attraverso una
strada attraverso la vedo un palazzo
antico e uno credere quella strada quel
palazzo l'ha visto solo lui no
invece non è così quella strada quel
palazzo che il convento qui che lo
spazio dove siamo più adesso il convento
dei benedettini quanti occhi l'hanno
visto quanti pensieri l'anno ha
tralasciato quante vite hanno respirato
questo spazio quelle stanze che stanno
attorno a quante e io a volte quando
sono nella mia città essendo questa
specie di pressione di latenza di
vissuto e di vissuti che premono su di
me basta un gesto per toccarli far
ritornare in vita e restituirli
attraverso le storie racconti e questo
mi capita questo è il rapporto con la
città e in questo senso del potere che
dentro la storia stratificata di
caltagirone
ma così come quello di catania di
qualsiasi spazio no perché lo spazio
verticale non è solo orizzontale
verticale dentro ogni spazio
ci sono milioni di storie milano gli
occhi milioni di possibilità ecco dentro
la verticalità di storia i vissuti di
caltagirone ho trovato le storie che ho
narrato e sono storie normali di di
donna donne non donne rassegnata ma
donne resistenti perché il passato non è
vuoto non a cevo e noi non siamo figli
figlie del nulla
noi abbiamo un passato storico abbiamo
una ad una storia delle madre e queste
mafie a volte hanno resistito hanno
detto no ho trovato delle donne è
veramente straordinarie veramente
sistemi le mie storie
partono da esistenza che poi si fanno
personaggi e si fanno personaggi
attraverso l'immaginario
nell'immaginario letterario perché solo
con l'immaginario tu puoi restituire a
vita da una
a una persona che non c'è più al passato
diciamo che ecco queste storie spesso
parto non solo da un dettaglio nel
capitato di trovare in vecchie cronache
in cronologie dei dettagli un piccolo
episodio e da quel piccolo episodio
magari che un gesto di una donna che si
è inserito dai giorni me e ho dovuto per
forza raccontarlo restituirle vita così
è capitato a queste storie di donne
io vorrei fare solo due esempi il primo
è una donna che il primo è la prima
storia che voglio così brevemente
accennato a cui voglio brevemente
accennare questa è una storia accaduta
nel 1698 e della storia di una donna una
povera donna non era george sanders una
povera donna che si traveste da uomo per
andare a lavorare in campagna è una
vedova era rimasta senza senza fini
senza nessuno aveva bisogno di lavorare
e quindi decide di andare di andare in
campagna perché questo sapeva fare ma
non avendo diciamo è qui che si direi
davano fastidio allora decise di appunto
di cambiare abbigliamento e di vestirsi
da uomo e di false poi è come dire
prendere assumere la giornata a me è
stata come si usava in quel tempo siamo
nel tempo in cui ci sono ancora in
queste zone in cui ci sono inquisizioni
cui c'è ancora tanto tanta tanta c'è
ancora adesso
ma c'era tanta preclusione alle donne di
accedere al lavoro eccetera
le vendite non importa e alla sua
dignità e deciso di farlo
ecco tutto questo sollecita chiacchiere
da parte di rete vicino eccetera
l'accusano di essere al di aver fatto un
patto col diavolo perché passa da uomo a
donna e da donna a uomo
naturalmente viene dio viene denunciato
all'inquisizione non vi dico come è una
storia che singolare questa non vi dico
come va a finire perché finisce in modo
altrettanto singolare
ecco lei voglio di questa è una storia
che erano di tre paginette non c'era il
mio io non sapevo chi era questo cioè
chi era suo marito
chi erano i suoi parenti cosa pensava
cosa mangiava cosa faceva
non sapevo niente saper solo questo
gesto ma questo gesto dentro di me
voleva avere ascolto voleva avere nella
voce voleva essere presentato francisca
io sapevo si amano francisca voleva
sapere restituita voce e io le ho
restituito a questa mia sorella remota
così come loro street ad un'altra
persona a tante altre donne vere diciamo
esistenze avere e poi ad un'altra
veramente singolarissima questa è una
donna particolare è una donna che ci
riguarda tutti perché riguarda il
fondamento uno degli episodi
fondamentali della nostra storia della
spedizione dei mille
la spedizione dei mille che normalmente
viene vissuta solo al maschile
c'era una donna tra il train il
cancellata non se ne sa più niente
scomparsa dai libri di storia scomparsa
anche dall'aneddotica rinascimento
risorgimentale e veramente singolare
anch'essa anche a lei io l'ho trovata
solo per un dettaglio una targa di cui
ebbe notizia in internet messa tanti
anni fa in un palazzo di firenze in cui
diceva qui è vissuta insieme al marito
francesco christie rosalie montmasson
l'unica donna dei mille io sono rimasta
allibita
perché io ho fatto ho studiato storia
con grandi maestri e poi all'università
di catania mazzarino già reggio grande
maestro grandi storici e quindi ho
insegnato storia filosofia o scelti
libri di testo per i miei alunni non
avevo mai trovato la notizia che c'era
una donna tra i mille quando seppi
questa cosa
dove ti dissi ma come è possibile
perché questo ostracismo della memoria
di questa donna così è accaduto ea quel
punto ho dovuto o con pensavo che una
notizia falsa invece non era fase ravera
comincerà a leggerlo cominciare a
cercare da cercare nei nei memorialisti
della prima ora a cercare negli archivi
e l'ho trovata a rosalie montmasson la
donna alla donna all'unica donna dei
mille
ecco cancellata dalla violenza di genere
e politica di suo marito francesco
crispi il cuore con insieme a lei lei
lava mantenute insieme aveva fatto
l'esilio per andati in esilio hanno
cospirato dopodiché si innamora lei
continua ad essere repubblicana lui
invece diventa monarchico lui lei resta
fedele a lui lui mail a tre donne si fa
annullare il matrimonio è di lei si
perde ogni traccia
questa è la storia di rosa di massa
della storia terribile raccontando
queste storie io non ho raccontato solo
il diciamo ecco il passato io ho
raccontato e presenza perché raccontando
di francisca di rosalia di un racconto
di me stessa di me maria attanasio sono
io che francisca sono io rosalia sono io
tutte le donne che hanno avuto che non
hanno avuto voce nella shell nella
nostra storia delle madri io sono quella
e questo per me è il senso della
scrittura scritture della presenza no
sia attraverso la metaforica attraverso
le storie che te la sua storia scrittura
della presenza qui e adesso
questo è per me la scrittura poetica e
narrativa fin da quando quella prima
volta la parola mi prese per mano e mi
ha accompagnato per tutta la vita
la parola mi prese per mano fuggendo il
dito adunco dell'inquisitore attraverso
morbi città assediate gorghi di noduli e
piastrine fino al risonante giardino
della città del giglio
la limite posa e fui sua figlia
ritornando talvolta in dormiveglia col
san benito della penitenza alta sul rogo
a sant'erasmo
[Musica]